alors le coup de coeur du ciné cette
semaine c'est le très beau film franco
iranien qui s'appelle le client alors je
prends ma fiche pour pas écorché le nom
du réalisateur parce que c'est un mirage
rien il s'appelle asghar farhadi ali
rahni 44 ont extrêmement talentueux
d'ailleurs un film a obtenu deux prix
majestueux au festival de cannes le prix
du scénario c'est un réalisateur qui est
très connu pour la qualité de ses
scénarios et le prix d'interprétation
masculine pour un monsieur qui s'appelle
saab hausse et me voilà on sert raconte
l'histoire d'un couple qui doivent qui
est obligés de déménager et qui va louer
un nouvel appartement et un incident lié
à l'ancien propriétaire va bouleverser
leur existence je vous en dis pas plus
asghar farhadi sait le spécialiste on va
dire de l'introspection du couple c'est
un film qui parle de la difficulté des
rapports entre hommes et femmes des
difficultés les rapports humains
c'est à la limite du thriller par
moments et c'est vraiment un très beau
film qui vient donc après les deux
autres film d'asghar farhadi qui sont
très connus comme le passé et séparation
venez le découvrir en version originale
dans nos salles
boubacar mansaly avait charmant
je crois
je vois ça avait marché cherche un job d
la main